as the community slowly returns back to
normal we're starting to see the ripple
effects of the pandemic
this is impacting businesses across the
board including the used car
industry kate houston digs deeper into
what's causing recent sky
high prices everything is like three
times the price like the inflation is
crazy
every dealer ship that we stopped by the
price is
way up high like this uncomparable
prices like you know can
afford it finding an affordable car has
now become a challenge for many
families it's frustrating because you
know we're already in a situation where
we're hanging on by a thread a lot of us
are not working or just getting back to
work and we really don't have
like a means of you know spending
exuberant amounts of money
dealers at charlie cheap car say higher
prices are due to a combination of
issues
the shutdowns less inventory on the new
car lots less trade-ins for the
for the new car stores therefore
everybody's scrambling a microchip
shortage is also keeping new cars in
factories
and causing prices of suvs to climb
drastically
you see some dealers new car dealers
around town that look like they're going
out of business just because they have
no inventory
this is making trade-ins even more
valuable what they might have been able
to get three thousand dollars for the
used car last year maybe it's forty five
hundred dollars now
cox automotive analysts expect these
prices to last through summer and
possibly into next year
we're just gonna have to ride it through
and see what happens
but i don't think it's anything
permanent although it may sound daunting
chance says there are options we
understand the short job time right now
we have lenders that are willing to work
with people who are just going back to
work after the pandemic
kate houston 8 news now cox automotive
says there are 1.4 million
fewer cars in inventory this year
compared to the same time last year
and that's about a 42 percent drop